[Música]
sabían que el 70 por ciento de los
cultivos de todo el mundo dependen en
alguna medida de la polinización que
hacen las abejas para producir frutas y
verduras
sin ellas no existirían manzanas peras
almendras altas tomates y un montón de
otras frutas y verduras
en el mundo existen más de 20.000
especies de abejas pero la gran mayoría
conocen solamente a una que se llama
apis mellifera que es la que produce la
miel que muchos consumimos
existen abejas de todo tipos existen
abejas negras verdes azules existen
abejas que no tienen aguijón no te pican
y existen a dejas que te pican y duele
existen abejas que hacen sus nidos en la
tierra otras que lo hacen en los árboles
otras que viven en comunidades y también
existen abejas que son solitarias
sin embargo tengo una mala noticia para
contarles
gran parte de estas especies de abejas
están desapareciendo y muchas centraron
en extinción
el mundo está atravesando una profunda
crisis de biodiversidad debido a que las
poblaciones de algunos insectos que son
clave para la producción de alimentos
están disminuyendo drásticamente
el uso de agroquímicos y también el
reemplazo de habitas naturales por
cultivos agrícolas son algunos de los
principales motivos que están
ocasionando esto
entonces me pregunto cómo vamos a hacer
si esta crisis se profundiza para
aumentar en un 70 por ciento la
producción de alimentos y abastecer a
las más de 9 mil millones de personas
que vamos a hacer para el año 2050 de
acuerdo las naciones unidas
hace un tiempo empecé a explorar el
mundo científico porque en el 2016 tres
años atrás fracasé emprendiendo
fue un golpe muy duro pero que me
permitió reflexionar y pensar y darme
cuenta que el propósito de la empresa en
la que estaba trabajando no me llenaba
del todo
tenía ganas de emprender de nuevo pero
quería que esta vez fuera distinto
tenía ganas de trabajar todos los días
en mi vida por algo que sí funciona
tener algún tipo de impacto positivo en
el mundo o agregar un granito de arena a
resolver algunos de los desafíos más
grandes que tenemos en la humanidad
decidí explorar el mundo científico un
mundo en el que yo no conocía
absolutamente nada no tenía ni amigos ni
familiares no sabía nada y eso era lo
que más me motiva me despertaba como esa
curiosidad saber
estará pasando ahí
entonces decidí empezar a juntarme a
tomar cafés con muchos científicos y me
sorprendí enormemente
conocí personas que dedican todos los
días de su vida con mucha pasión y
muchas veces con pocos recursos a
estudiar temas muy importantes para la
vida
por ejemplo conocí a unos científicos en
tucumán que desarrollaron un proceso
biotecnológico para que a partir de
bacterias produzcamos celulosa y podamos
reducir el impacto ambiental que tiene
la deforestación también conocí a otro
científico que había desarrollado una
tecnología que se llama nano vehículos
qué se utiliza para reducir
considerablemente la cantidad de
agroquímicos que se necesitan para
controlar a las plagas en la agricultura
y en esos cafés conocí a pedro y agustín
que son dos investigadores del conicet
hace más de diez años se dedican a
estudiar a las abejas ya la polinización
de cultivos
pedro negro es biólogo es investigador
hace más de 10 años se dedica a estudiar
el sistema inmunológico de las abejas en
la universidad de mar del plata hizo un
doctorado sobre eso
por otro lado agustín saiz también es
biólogo hizo un doctorado estudiando la
polinización de cultivos en bariloche en
la universidad nacional del comahue
en esos cafés también conocí a otra
persona que se llama walter fariña
walter hace más de 20 años se dedica a
estudiar cómo funciona el cerebro de las
abejas si escucharon bien hace más de 20
años dedica a todos los días de su vida
a estudiar cómo funciona el cerebro de
las abejas lo hace en la uva en la
facultad de ciencias exactas
y le pregunté es para qué no las abejas
van a buscar polen y néctar en las
flores y no van a todas las flores por
igual van algunas que les interesan más
porque tienen más recursos tienen quizás
más néctar que otras y eso es un desafío
al momento de polinizar las plantas
porque por ejemplo los cultivos de
arándanos las flores tienen poco néctar
ya las abejas no les atrae y la
polinizar esa flor que necesita de las
abejas para producir arándanos
entonces walter encontrar una manera de
condicionar la memoria de las abejas
para entrenarlas a que vayan a polinizar
flores de arándano y que no se
distraigan con otras flores a través de
la alimentación de lo que le da de comer
a las abejas algo similar al
condicionamiento
no sé si conocen el de pablo con el del
perro
y porque esto es importante porque
cuanto más polen se deposita en una flor
más semillas va a producir el fruto y
cuantas más semillas más grande va a ser
este fruto
quiero cuando van a la verdulería y ven
una manzana chica y una manzana grande
si huelen a sus casas y cortan esa
manzana a la mitad van a ver la cantidad
de semillas que tiene la manzana más
chica va a tener menos semillas que la
manzana más grande y se tiene que ver
con que antes de esa manzana había una
flor y las abejas depositaron menos
polen que en la manzana más grande lo
mismo pasa con los kiwis vieron cuando
cortan un kiwi la mitad tiene semillas
negras
el kiwi más chico va a tener menos
semillas que vivo y más grande y eso
tiene que ver de vuelta con la cantidad
de polen que depositaron las abejas en
la flor que existía antes de que nazca
el kiwi o con las frutillas cuando ven
una frutilla un poco deforme bueno eso
tiene que ver en general con una mala
polinización
la polinización es un proceso biológico
fundamental para la vida
es un proceso complejo pero estudiar la
interacción entre los polinizadores y
las plantas nunca tuvo tanta relevancia
en la historia de la humanidad
y en argentina tenemos alguno de los
mejores científicos del mundo trabajando
en este tema
sin embargo aunque no lo crean gran
parte de los productores agrícolas no
los conocen no saben ni que existen
entonces me pregunte por qué pasa esto
porque tenemos conocimiento que nos
llega a la vida de las personas
y empecé a estudiar un poquito como
pensaban los científicos con el
propósito de los científicos cuál es su
para qué no y encontré una respuesta un
patrón en esa respuesta bastante simple
con el cual probablemente muchos
científicos que están aquí presentes
coincidan
los científicos llevan a cabo todos los
días de su vida una tarea muy noble
la de expandir la frontera del
conocimiento
qué significa eso
significa responder preguntas que no
fueron respondidas y también continuar
con investigaciones que fueron
inconclusas para entender factores
importantes en la vida
y porque lo hacen lo hacen porque
esperan que algún día ese conocimiento
impacte en la vida de las personas
y fue allí cuando encontré paralelismo
entre sus propósitos y lo que yo estaba
buscando como emprendedor y quería armar
una empresa que genera un impacto
positivo en el mundo
entonces dije podrán coexistir el mundo
de los emprendimientos con el de los
científicos
podrán ser las empresas un vehículo a
través del cual aumente las
probabilidades de que ese conocimiento
impacte de forma positiva en el mundo
en argentina tenemos muchísimos
científicos muchos más de los que les
mencioné hay de todos los colores
tenemos la mayor cantidad de científicos
para cápita de latinoamérica y más del
70% de ellos trabajando en ciencias de
la vida qué significa eso la
biotecnología entre otras cosas además
tenemos una historia que nos acompaña
con más de tres premios nobeles de
ciencia
y además por último tenemos también
empresas en la industria de
biotecnología con desarrollos de primer
nivel mundial en farm a alimentos
energía y agro
pero que tengamos todo esto para mí no
es suficiente porque que el conocimiento
científico quede publicado en un
artículo académico es importante pero no
es suficiente porque nos llega la vida
de las personas y este es un problema
que tenemos en la argentina
pero también está en muchos otros países
y hoy les quiero proponer una solución
una solución que tiene un potencial de
transformación gigante
pero depende de cada uno de ustedes que
eso pase
necesitamos personas que se junten con
los científicos e intenten cambiar el
mundo
necesitamos emprendedores que se animen
a meterse en ese mundo llamado
biotecnología
y quiero proponer también otra cosa que
se acerquen a la ciencia que sean más
curiosos que salgan de su zona de
confort y que se junten a tomar un café
como lo hice yo hace tres años con
científicos y les pregunten
cómo puedo colaborar como te puedo
ayudar para que ese conocimiento impacte
de forma positiva en la vida de las
personas
después de conocer a pedro y agustín
juntos armamos una empresa que se llama
baby flow
be flow aplica conocimientos científicos
en la polinización que hacen las abejas
para aumentar la producción de alimentos
de forma sustentable mientras
resguardamos la salud de las mismas
en esta aventura decidimos sumar a
walter farina porque consideramos que su
conocimiento científico específico sobre
cómo entrenar a las abejas era
fundamental para hacer más eficiente la
polinización aumentar la producción de
alimentos junto a él éramos una empresa
que se llama to be
en los últimos tres años pudimos validar
que el conocimiento científico argentino
en este tema tiene un potencial de
impacto enorme a nivel global
trabajando con más de 10 empresas en
argentina y en eeuu pudimos aumentar
entre un 20 y un 90% la cantidad de
kilos producidos por hectárea con
cultivos de kiwis almendras arándanos y
frambuesas
y lo hicimos comparando la manera
tradicional de por iniciar un cultivo
con la nuestra
en beef lo alimentamos a las abejas con
moléculas orgánicas para fortalecer su
sistema inmunológico y se nos permite
que las abejas estén más fuertes para
polinizar los cultivos más desafiantes
que son los que florecen en el invierno
en argentina en julio en agosto los
cultivos de almendras y arándanos por
ejemplo también alimentamos a las abejas
con otras moléculas para entrenarlas a
que vayan a flores específicas y
aumentar su eficiencia al priorizar las
plantas y por último estudiamos de qué
manera podemos ubicar las colmenas de
forma estratégica
para maximizar la interacción entre las
plantas y los polinizadores y que así se
maximiza la producción
de hecho hace poco conseguimos un gran
hito para nuestra empresa
driscoll es la empresa más grande del
mundo en producciones frutillas
arándanos y frambuesas decidió empezar a
polinizar sus cultivos en california en
eeuu con el conocimiento científico
argentino
además conseguimos otro hito muy
importante que fue nuestro primer
artículo científico y fue una
demostración de que las empresas también
pueden acelerar el desarrollo de ese
conocimiento y yo estoy allí como
coautor junto a pedro y agustín un
licenciado en administración de empresas
en una revista académica internacional
sobre polinización la verdad
nunca me lo hubiese imaginado
las empresas son quizás el mejor
vehículo para transferir el conocimiento
científico a la vida de las personas
las empresas pueden transformar
realidades
pueden acelerar el conocimiento
científico mucho más de lo que muchos
creen
faltan emprendedores que se animen junto
a los científicos a generar empresas de
base científica
porque científicos con ideas en el mundo
sobran y muchos están acá con ustedes
sentados al lado suyo
faltan emprendedores que se animen a
trabajar junto a ellos para intentar
cambiar el mundo muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]